[Music]
what Einstein did in 1905 his first
theory of relativity that would be
enough for most people but he had
another idea a more powerful idea which
came together in 1915 when he was in his
mid-30s the middle of World War one and
it's called general relativity and it's
a magnificent idea if he hadn't come up
with it I doubt if anybody else would
have in the more than century since then
and it's a notion of explaining how all
of space and time and all of matter and
everything's organized and what's
amazing is instead of it being a long
complicated Dell thing he got it down to
two little symbols and this was
extraordinary he thought who had created
a universe where all the complexity we
see the spinning of the earth around the
Sun the how the galaxy moves if it moves
at all that all this could be explained
in terms of two simple symbols and he
thought this was fabulous and then he
looked at his symbols and he realized
hmm they predicted that the universe was
expanding he asked his astronomer
friends 1917-1918
is the universe in fact expanding and
they said no it's it's static they
thought at that time the universe was
just the Milky Way galaxy a whole bunch
of stars floating there in space and
beyond there there was just an empty
void it was it was sort of like Donald
Trump's brain there was just angry
magnetic fields full of nothing and
Einstein thought are you sure and they
said well that's kind of what the
universe is like so we had to change
that beautiful simple equation and had
to put in X an extra term which he
symbolized by the lambda and instead of
thinking mmm God or the old one or
whatever force there's behind the
universe had made something very simple
for us to discover there's this ugly
equation this additional term this sort
of canceled the expansion anyways about
ten years later 1929 Edwin Hubble in
California and other people said oh you
were we wrong they probably didn't say
the word we were we wrong they said the
universe is expanding after all an
Einstein thought the good news is I get
to take away the lambda that extra term
I can go back to that beautiful simple
clear thing I discovered back in 1915
and general relativity and that's okay
that's an allowable mistake I don't
think that's his greatest mistake the
great mistake came after that
he drew a psychological conclusion he
concluded that he was wrong to listen to
experimental evidence because he
believed that the universe should be
crisp and clear and exact from now on if
he had those beliefs and experimental
evidence came up that contradicted it he
could ignore it remember he would have
been right he would have been right to
ignore all the evidence that we the
astronomers thought about the shape of
the universe they were wrong for ten
years well it turns out in the late
1920s when Einstein had this
breakthrough or this idea that's when
quantum mechanics was coming in the
study of the ultra-small electrons
things like that and they seemed to move
around that in the clear beautiful ways
that Einstein wanted but there's
randomness and chance and probability
and Einstein thought okay that's you
know the limits of our technical
abilities our observations only see this
fuzziness but we if we have better tools
we'll be able to see things more exactly
Einstein thought that things like
uncertainty were just a temporary stage
and mankind's development but the
physicist said no the evidence is really
clear and Einstein said I was burned
once before with that lambda and the
expansion of the universe I'm not gonna
be burned again so he dug in he doubled
up and as time went on the evidence for
quantum mechanics for this randomness
and probability on the ultra-small that
evidence became stronger and stronger
but Einstein I'm saying was stuck he
couldn't let go he just thought if I
held my my confidence for ten years
before I would have been okay well maybe
it might be twenty years maybe it might
be beyond my lifetime but I'm sure
Einstein thought I'm sure that the
universe can't be disordered that's why
he said God does not play dice with the
universe and it's good friend nails Bohr
said Einstein stop telling God what to
do
[Music]